Trump is considering four women who else
is there there's Nikki Haley who is
running against him and uh Trump
apparently believes she won't take any
votes from him so she's not really a
danger
another idea is Arkansas governor Sarah
Huckabee Sanders who was Trump's White
House Press Secretary
that's uh pretty wild and then fourth is
South Dakota Governor Christie gnome
who's often mentioned by Trump
confidants although I don't know that
she carries the faux gravitas of uh of
of Carrie Lake I can't believe this is
real life but it is true and of course
when you step back you say she has an
unblemished record of never winning
anything she's a complete Trump suck-up
she lies uncontrollably and constantly
that seems like it would make her a bad
candidate but that actually is seen as
making her a good candidate